hallo leute hier ist wieder einmal war
der uns mit yan star es nach
unternehmens geändert hessen und vendome
hier ist dann testen die natürlich einen
ich hab' ich habe sogar nudeln gemacht
dass stimmen das ist derart von spiritus
ja das ist der amazon alkohol ins
kalender ich weiß nicht ob sie dieses ob
sie jemals schon einen rausgebracht
haben aber dieses jahr gibt allen er
heißt premium adventskalender hat 80
euro gekostet und naomi also willst du
dich hatte dann lief dazu bekommen und
da sind sogar auch türchen war das heißt
man kann sich nicht mehr steigern
ja und wir würden nicht lang schnacken
wir machen jetzt einfach die türchen auf
und besitzt du die ehre haben das erste
türchen auf zwei wegen wird als
branntwein klassifizierten ist bei ihr
weil man den zusatz weinen nicht falsch
verstehen das ist doch geil einfach
irgendwas ich immer noch gar nichts über
denn ja doch kartoffel hat gar nicht aus
kartoffeln denn auch
dann lege ich es für meine literatur zur
seite und dann widmen wir uns den
richtigen sachen türchen nummer eins gab
es ging also was jetzt kommt ist noch
nicht passiert dass gottes gibt es geht
das schottler verkostung snow tubes
überraschende süße salz und hoffe also
ich würde nicht sagen aber
ausschließlich oder wohl scoach ist das
ist die flasche an flasche sowie reimann
so klare farbe toll toll das sieht man
das ist typisch für den lernerfolg süß
und dort das ist halt echt toll wie er
das können sie mir nicht erzählen
gänsehaut bis zum 8 also für mich ist
ein bisschen so natürlich in so ein
autoreifen reinbeißen
schick schick dollar 2
den kenne ich sogar und der ist wirklich
sehr lecker es läuft ich mich also ich
sage nur der sanieren hinweis in einem
mit eis gefüllten longdrinkglas geben
und mit tonic water auf diesen das heißt
sie sagen 'bitte nicht betrinken ja
probieren wir die netze nicht ja
wenig mediziner volk offen und von
kräutern zitrusfrucht also im vergleich
zu dem davor als der definitiv werfer
haben die aussagen ja also nicht die
street tüchern normal 3
wisst ihr was ist denn daran special mit
wachstum
das schon cool
will ich gar nicht aufmachen ich auf den
verschenke ich einfach irgendwie
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
youtuber krankheit hinter theresa ist
ein kräftiger elegant herum aus
venezuela ein blend mit roms eine
drohung
nein nein
hier stehen vielerorts noten von dörfler
und vanille mit einem hauch von
gerösteten mandeln und karamell das hat
ja nicht ganz da zusätzlich mutter und
ich glaube es auch gar nicht so eklig
oder das waren toll dass geschoss hatte
mich gerade vorgemacht
[Musik]
also wirklich immer noch bin ich der
meinung der erste war bisher einfach nur
am schlimmsten die anderen gingen gut zu
erwidern keine zeit verlieren team
wartet ganz ehrlich und was wartet der
uns auf rund nummer vier glenlivet
scotch whisky verkostung weich und lebt
mit noten von haselnuss und marzipan
also viel besser als erste das ist okay
das ist dan fängt an zu vergeben
also wird es jetzt ein bisschen rum
whiskey und also ich hoffe wir mal
jetzt also zweiter wird kann ich jetzt
auch schon zu lassen also ist dann auch
kein wein oder sogar davon aus schon
beton das sind ja aber der sie besonders
auf bittersüßen orangen oder das
klassische moderne chris holder immer
dabei koriander angelika schuster hat
und somit dieser mythos ist ganz geil
man möchte es ja ich komme ja sagen ja
das ist naomis geburtstag der 6 b 12
und jetzt wird für dich dein allerliebst
lieblings alkohol drin sein nämlich
zwar kostet uns so tief weich hauch von
honig gefolgt von torf es ist wieder top
[Musik]
was also was haben denn die ideal als
begleiter zu gericht mit callte rind
lamm wild wurstwaren und milchprodukten
kannst du schöne stück salami wohl nur
genannt timo an seiner hand
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bacardi vanille gerösteten ecke und
honig schauen wir uns also schon wieder
wusste immer was ich kann mir wie du
trinkst das hier ist sonst häufig trump
[Musik]
schreiben 7
heute für sie ein z 44/10 südtiroler
christian unverwechselbar mit
die botanika als wären zwei stunden kalt
gemacht maturiert und trinkt stärker
einstellung und viel traktion spürst du
die filtration das wirklich da der
erfahrung für sich
magst du denn etwa die note von limetten
ein bisschen kräutertee und zapfen eine
gute prise wacholder
anders für mich allerdings schon sehr
ähnlich geschmeckt ist auch der zweite
der war schon das wasser auch die immer
noch ein stück
bailey 12 kann's kaum erwarten
[Musik]
ja darüber leben jetzt erstmal artikel
seine crew ski und sind gut das wusste
ich noch gar nie scharf sind whiskey
aroma gelder sind jetzt richtig happy
drauf dann nimmt sondern direkt ob das
aber so wie ich mutig sein will aber
doch nicht so schöne farbe hier toll
toll toll toll toll toll super toll
riecht aber immer wieder wieder erste
top ist
das ist in dem glas und ziemlich lecker
1 33 prozent nicht ganz so genau sagen
33 prozent mit ja bei santa barbara
barbara barbara bach das ist okay brust
husten und ab damit zurück in die
zauberkugel 16
martin bureau das ist wirklich mal was
also ist okay ich bin ein bisschen im
adventskalender ich bin immer ehrlich
das ist mit zu viel whisky das ist
wirklich vieles geht aber ich glaube da
der auch für alkohol kenn ich glaube die
leute stehen auch wissen was ist das
denn das ist ja mein gott also es ist
macht die niveau und es ist ein moderner
aperitif der perfekt für das mixen mit
onyx trinkt will leute für intensives
zitrusnoten und ein komplexer charakter
wie ich ja kann ich mir vorstellen noch
mit so weit wären oder ich mach martin
glaub ich ganz gerne schmeckt immer so
ein bisschen nach oliven mögen also
dieses leicht betrunken
vielleicht ein bisschen ja aber wenn ich
also wenn ich diese rote flecken kriege
dann geht es los
wenn die bahn den 17 musik fred drive-in
weltweit ausgezeichnete einmal lebendig
so ich nehme auch der kaffee schmeckt
schon also auch gar nicht so stark das
hätte man schon ein bisschen wasser
ringen so weitergeht würde 18
es gibt doch mehr getrieben bis irland
erzeugen halte zudem probieren nein wir
sind auf der zielgeraden
das ist schon mal in 20 jahren 1919
seine mit moskaus kein scherz war dass
dann viele fans liga rocken was ist das
kabel hat sie dem ok ein wodka likör in
dem vollmundiger karamell geschmack und
der unverfälschte geschmack von soja
oder ist ja einfach nur zwischen schnell
war wenn man den gekühlt trinken wir
dafür so behalten wir uns nur mal konnte
man muss auch dazu sagen jetzt immer
wenn es darum geht also wohl da können
wir sagen es habe schon probiert den
habe ich schon probiert und den übrigens
auch was seine über die übel dann haben
wir zu viele häuser drin kann er mag
dann den limette denn diese mode vom
dorf ist mir einfach zu überwiegend wir
können das jetzt auch nicht bringen
für die unterbrechung ist und mir leid
ich möchte mich an dieser stelle auch
noch mal bei euch entschuldigen ich
verteile ist das von tonkabohne
abgeleitet die tonkabohne verteilten
verleiht ungeborene vergleich denn seine
unverwechselbaren eleganten und
einzigartigen geschmack nur im wie süß
vanille habe mit mantel und würzige
hoffnungen tragen diesen besonderen
geschmackserlebnis zeigen sehr würzig
tonkabohne so eine art bohne 28
das ist ein betörendes gehört da ist es
marin in der tonkabohne aphrodisiakum
erotische wirkung
machen insider 22 4 siege ramelow du du
es anders in der hacienda produziert
vanille trockenfrüchte tabak und
schokolade war ist in der tabak und
schokolade
[Musik]
jeder hat irgendwo mit seiner gitarre so
stark ist die note die wir brauchen also
schokolade schmecken die tabak schmeckt
hier nochmal 23
[Gelächter]
jim beam bekommen die nummer vier und
zwei
o-ton schlangenhaut das glaube ich schon
gesehen könnte das etwas schön soll's
gehen jinman kräfte germany drei orangen
pink grapefruit limetten zitronen und
ersten verfügen ganz ehrlich ich hab da
so sieht sie aus als ob wieder ein paar
den perfekt kopf ab gemacht hätten und
jetzt so wie schmeckte für elise
trainerinnen parfüm probe centers oder
es schmeckt irgendwie ich weiß ob man
das nicht trinken dürfte das war der
matula aber ich zumindest nicht und ist
auch nicht schnell ja hast du fazit
kommen also man weiß ja wohl was unser
lieblingsgetränk war oder auf wm-platz
oscar ja ja ich finde sein okay für aber
ich habe auch ein bisschen angst dass
wenn du sowas verschenkt du bist doch
danach derzeit halt auch alkoholiker
ich glaube ehrlich sagen wenn du sowas
verschenkt wird sondern mein team
einfluss sind einfach wirklich nie
angefasst abonniert auf den kanal wenn
ihr nicht weiteres verpassen wollt
schreibt einige kommentare was für ein
adventskalender je nach sehen wollt und
in der video beschreibung findet ihr sie
noch nicht kennt die macht nämlich auch
youtube und tik tok und instagram hoch
[Musik]
macht's gut und danke dass du das gerne